Hi.
In this class, we'll be reviewing the concept
of material functions, and we'll
be creating a really cool dissolve effect transition
material from the ground up.
Let's get started.
Now, you know the deal at this point.
Since the exercise today will be quite extensive,
I'll be jumping directly into the engine
and close the slides.
Remember that each step that I will be taking in Unreal
will also be displayed through screenshots and instructions
here in the PowerPoint file provided with this course.
Together with the sample material and its embedded
material function we will check out in just a moment,
you should be able to walk in the right direction
as we draft a new material out.
We also have some comments and explanations
in the finished graphs for you
to understand what's happening under the hood.
But we'll also be talking about them
as we build the new materials out.
Our goal for today is to create a dissolve effect
transition.
We'll be storing this effect into a material function
to easily have access to it whenever we need it.
So let's fire up the engine and see how to achieve that.
So today, we're not going to be working from our default map.
So let's click on this icon over here
and browse through the era of the content browser
where this map is stored together with some other ones.
And the map we're going to be using today
is called MatDissolveSample.
So let's double click on it to open it up.
OK.
What we have displayed here are three example objects
sharing the final look of the material
we'll be developing today.
And as you can see, the animated texture on it,
it's quite fast, and we're getting some artifacts.
That's because Lumen struggles when
trying to compute glowing effects with fast movements.
Let's try to slow it down a little.
So I'm just going to select one of the meshes
with this material.
And if we open up its material instance from the Details panel,
we would find out that we wouldn't
be able to tweak the texture speed directly
from the material instance because it wasn't
exposed to any parameter.
We'd need to open up its parent material down here.
And then if we pan a little bit to the left,
we'll find this Panner node.
And if we switch the speed Y to 0.2 and then save our
changes and navigate back to our map,
we would see that now the speed of the animated texture
would be reduced.
So the parent material that we just opened
is the finished product that we will be developing today.
And together with its material function
that you can find here in the middle,
and you can open up by double clicking on it,
you should be able to follow along.
And if you ever get stuck, you
can always go back to either the material function
or the master material and review the final product.
OK, so I'm going to be closing all of those down now.
And let's go ahead and start building our material
from scratch.
So I'm going to navigate to the in class material folder.
And then under Dissolve in Class,
I'm going to be creating our parent material
that I'm going to be calling M underscore Dissolve.
And then I'm going to be creating a material function
by right clicking in the content browser
and then navigating to Material, Advanced,
and Material Function.
The main naming convention for this one
is MF underscore, and then I'm going
to be calling it teleporter.
Then I'll Control-Shift-S to save all my changes.
All right, let's go ahead and open up
our material function.
All right, so first of all, if we check out
the stats panel, we can see that we're
getting an arrow because we're missing
the function output result.
And that's really just because we're previewing this node
already, even though nothing is connected to it.
So if we right click on it and stop previewing the node,
that arrow will be gone.
Now, before we get started, I just
wanted to mention that we've talked in depth
about material functions in the Masking Materials and Material
Functions course already.
So if you haven't checked that out yet,
I'd encourage you to watch that series of classes
first to better understand what we'll be developing today.
The development of material functions
can be quite abstract if you're just
following along without having a rough idea
of the final picture.
And we won't be able to preview what we're creating today
until we really embed this material function
into its parent material and play around with its parameters
in a material instance.
So I'll be overlaying some visual previews
of the final product as we draft this out.
And this should help you better understand what we're doing.
All right, let's start out by panning a little bit
to the left because this material is
going to be quite extensive and will need a lot of space.
OK, then in an empty area of the graph,
I'm going to be right clicking and search for a bounding box
based 0 to 1 UV.
So this bounding box material function
is actually a material function
that generates normalized UV coordinates in the 0 to 1
range based on an object bounding box.
A bounding box is an invisible rectangular box
that perfectly fits around your entire 3D object.
And since it is a material function, as I just mentioned,
if you double click on it, you will
be able to actually see how it was developed.
But as usual, make sure to not apply any changes
if you move any nodes around because this material function
is part of our edging content.
So I'm just going to close it down.
And the first we want to do is actually
invert this 0 to 1 range with a 1 minus node.
So I'm going to drag out of the RGB output pin
and then search for 1 minus.
OK, now we want to go on and create a function input.
Function input represent the exposed pins
when a material function gets embedded
into its parent material.
They kind of work like parameters
for material instances.
In this first section of the graph,
we will be exposing a few pins to be able to control
the way we cut our material.
And this vector tree constant in particular
will allow us to define the shape and overall extension
of the cut in the x, y, and z vertex position of our object.
Because as usual, the RGB values of a vector tree node
represent the x, y, and z-coordinates in the world.
So a full red would mean a full cut in the x-axis.
A full green would mean a full cut in the y-axis.
And a full blue, a full cut in the z-axis.
For now, we're going to keep this value as black.
So let's name this function input plane cut.
And make sure that use preview value as default is turned on.
We're going to leave the sort priority at 0.
OK, now after this 1 minus node,
we want to be adding a dot product.
So I'm going to extend out of the output pin
and then type dot to create a dot product.
And then we want to connect the output
pin of the plane cut to the b input of the dot.
Now the dot product computes the length of one vector
projected onto another.
We've also used it in the development
of cotton and silk-like shaders in lesson 3 for faking effects.
Now since we're using the bounding box material function,
the result of this dot product
will be local space or object-oriented,
so relative to our object.
If we were to rotate the object around in the 3D space,
the cut will stay as it is, as you can see.
Now we want to add more granular control over our cut.
And we want to define where exactly it will
take place on our object.
So let's add one more function input
and call it length, then switch its input type from vector 3
to scalar, and then make sure that use preview value
as default is turned on.
Now what we get from the dot product
is basically a gradient ranging from 0
to 1 across our chosen axis, either the x, the y, or the z.
If we now drag out of the dot product
and we add a divide node, we're
basically scaling down the gradient range
that we've got from the dot product
and essentially zooming into it.
So let's plug the length scalar output
into the b input of the divide.
And since this division is happening after our dot
product is not going to impact the cut in its three
dimensions, this scalar function input
will just allow us to basically tweak
how extended our cut will be.
Now let's allow ourselves to add a texture on top
of the sliced area only.
So by pressing A on my keyboard and clicking
on an empty area of the graph, I will be adding an add node.
And then I will connect the output
pin of the divide node to the a.
And I will go down here and add yet one more function input
that I will be calling texture.
I will use the prevalue as default
and then set the sort priority to 2.
And let's make also sure that the length scalar has
a sort priority of 1.
OK, now let's create one more function input that's
going to be called fake texture.
It's going to be a scalar.
We're going to use the prevalue as default.
And its sorting priority is going to be 3.
And then if I press M on the keyboard
and click on an empty area of the graph, I can add a multiply.
And we want to multiply the input texture with the input
fake texture.
Basically, by multiplying these two nodes,
we're defining how much of the texture
we want to see based on the sliced area
that it is applied to.
So let's now connect the multiply output pin
to the B input of the add.
OK, now let's add even more granular control here.
I'm going to be moving the output result to the side.
And now we want to be able to linearly dissolve
the sliced area without distorting its extension.
So if I extend out of the add node,
we can add add subtract node that will
allow us to do exactly that.
Now let's create one more function input
that we're going to be calling dissolve offset.
It's going to be a scalar used for the value as default.
And the sorting priority is going to be 4.
And then we want to plug it to the B
input of the subtract.
OK, now let's compare it with the length function input
that we exposed.
While the length will either extend or reduce
the overall area of our cut, the dissolve scalar
will simply allow us to offset the sliced area
along our subject.
Now as we expand this node, we need
the result of this subtract node to range from 0 to 1
rather than larger values, especially
because we'll be using it as an alpha mask in lerp nodes
as we move along.
So we want to add a clamp node after this subtract
before proceeding further.
And this is going to be providing us
with more predictable results because we're
going to be keeping the range from 0 to 1.
So now we're able to granularly control our sliced
area and offset it around if we want to.
We can also add a texture to it
and define how much of the texture we want to see.
Now let's give us more artistic control
by allowing us to tint the interior surface of our sliced
area to any color we want.
So let's add one more function input.
I know that's a lot of function inputs.
And we're going to be calling it interiorTint.
The input type is going to be vector3.
We want to use the preview value as default.
And the sort priority is going to be 5.
Now we want to be adding the tint only to our sliced area.
So we'll need to use the result of this clamp node
as alpha mask in a lerp.
So let's press L on the keyboard
and click in an interior of the graph
and then connect the clamp to the alpha,
interiorTint to the A,
and then I'm going to be pressing 1 on my keyboard
and add a constant value of 0
that we're really going to be using as a dummy value
because we don't want the tint to be applied
to the unsliced area of our object at all.
So I'm just going to be plugging it to the B.
Okay, if we see an example of how the material
looks like now, we can see this black area
on the interior part of our object.
That's because our shader is not two-sided.
So only its outer normals are being calculated.
We need a way to tell Unreal that we want our tint
to affect the interior side of the object.
And we have a very useful material expression to do that
called two-sided sign.
So let's right-click in an emptier of the graph
and add a two-sided sign expression.
Now we want to use this two-sided sign information
as the driver and alpha to define
where we will be displaying our texture
versus the tinted color.
So let's add one more Lerp node by pressing L
on the keyboard and left-clicking on the graph.
And then we want to plug the two-sided sign
into the alpha, the result of the Lerp to the B,
and the interior tint to the A.
Now the result of this Lerp node
can be connected to the output result.
And it will be providing us with the formation
to cover the emissive color of our main material.
But we need one more output pen
to output our opacity mask for our main material
because this material needs to have transparent areas.
Now for now, we've always been dealing
with function inputs to allow anybody
using our material function
to input information into our function.
And now we're gonna be right-clicking on the graph
and we're gonna be adding a function output
to add another output pen to our material function.
Now let's go ahead and rename
this first function output to emissive.
And we can keep the sort priority to zero.
And then this second function output
is gonna be called opacity mask.
And the sort priority is gonna be one.
And lastly, we wanna connect the output pen of the clamp
to the output opacity mask, okay?
The last thing we wanna do now before applying our changes
is just clicking in an empty area of the graph
and then expose our material function to our library.
Now we can save
and the changes will be applied automatically.
Okay, let's click on this icon over here
to navigate to the content browser
and open up our parent material.
The first thing we wanna do
is click in an empty area of the graph
and change the blend mode from opaque to masked
to have access to the opacity mask.
Then we wanna right-click on base color
and promote these two parameter.
And this base color is basically gonna be
the color of our unslized area.
So I'm gonna double-click on it
and you can choose any color you want.
I'm gonna choose something like orange.
Now we can right-click in an empty area of the graph
and then type mf teleporter
to embed our material function into its parent material.
And then we can right-click on plain cut
and promote two parameter.
And we can color these fully blue
cause we want our cut to happen on the Z axis.
Then let's right-click on length and promote two parameter.
We can keep the length at zero
but let's change the slider max value to three
to contain the maximum length.
Now let's right-click in an empty area of the graph
and add a texture sample.
And then we want to right-click on it
and convert these two parameter.
And we can just simply call it texture effects.
The type of texture we wanna use
is the widget grid vertex color material.
And then if we press P on our keyboard
and left-click in an empty area of the graph
we can add a panner to animate this texture.
And we can set the speed Y to something small like 0.2
and then connect the output pin of the panner
to the UVs of the texture effects
and then the RGB of the texture effect to the texture.
Then we can right-click
and promote the fade texture to parameter.
And we can set its slider mean to something like minus one
and the max to 0.5.
Okay, then let's right-click on the dissolve effect
and promote two parameter
and we can set the slider max to one.
Lastly, let's right-click on interior tint
and promote that to parameter as well.
And let's give it a tint that we can see like pink.
Now we can go ahead and plug the output pin
of the opacity mask into the input bit
of the opacity mask of our main material.
And then we want to be able to control
the strength of our emissive.
So let's press S on our keyboard
to create a scalar parameter
that we can call emissive strength.
Now we want to press M to multiply it.
So let's connect the emissive output
of the MF teleporter to the A
and the emissive strength to the B.
And then let's connect the output pin of the multiplier
to the emissive color.
Okay, we can save and then navigate to our viewport.
And in here, we can right-click on our parent material
and then create a material instance for it.
So I'm going to be calling it MI and the score dissolve
and control shift dash apply all.
Okay, now if I drag this material instance
onto one of the cans,
it's going to be applied directly.
And let's double-click on it to have it here undocked.
I'm going to be playing around with the dissolve offset,
the emissive strength, the fade texture, and the length.
Let's start by playing a bit with the length.
You can see here that our material will start dissolving
and right now the fade texture is set to zero
so we don't see any texture at all.
And if we increase the emissive strength,
also our interior tint will start shining through.
And here with the dissolve offset,
you can see that we can really define
where this cut is happening on the can.
Let's switch back to our slides now.
So that was it for this class,
but you can find some additional documentation at this link
if you're interested in further expanding your knowledge
in material functions.
And here you can also find even more resources
to dive deeper into animated materials
and customize them to your liking.
We're almost at the end of this entire series of classes
on translucent materials and VFX.
We won't be diving into hands-on exercises
or new theories any further,
but in the upcoming lessons, we will do a recap
on everything we learned so far and say our goodbyes.
Thank you for sticking around and I'll see you there.
Bye.